I played EDH wrong for years. In the
early days, I remember looking up how to
win games, listening to podcasts, and
one advice I got was to always lay low,
pretend to be harmless, and let others
fight it out. And when they're done, I
swoop in for a victory. And most
importantly, play a deck that can allow
us to do that. Accumulating resources
early for big explosive boom booms late.
The podcast was called Competitive Cast.
Some older players might remember. It
was a time when magic content wasn't
nearly as [music] widely available, but
I dug and I found it. The secret
techniques. And I was going to tell none
of my friends. They didn't listen to EDH
podcasts. They had lives. So, for
months, my games looked like this. "Wee,
I have nothing. Don't target me."
Cultivate. "Wee, look, I still have no
board." End of turn Blue Sun's Zenith
for eight. "Wee, I drew all lands,
though." End of turn Cyclonic Rift on
top of Avenger of Zendikar with five
counter spells back up. "Oh, surprise, I
took that one. Close game, guys." Pretty
quickly, though, it became boring. And
that's the truth about EDH, the format.
Winning should be rare. With four
players, your base chance is 25%. Adding
variance, and you can easily go entire
sessions without a single victory. And
that should be the norm. If you want to
win noticeably more, you probably have
to push your percentage closer to 40 or
higher. And that number comes directly
at someone else's expense. So, if
winning is your only goal, Commander
might not be the right game. Now, this
sounds stupid simple, but it took me a
while to figure out. Here's the
not-so-simple part. So, if we aren't
measuring success in the format by wins,
what do we use? How do we get better at
a game we like to think is skill-based?
And this is where we bring in the F
word. Fun. But this is the other
extreme. Fun is impossible to quantify.
I played in groups where everyone just
showed up to exhibit their weirdest deck
builds from half tribal to 12-piece Rube
Goldberg machines. Everyone just jer uh
jerk uh juggled their pieces for
everyone else to see. Yes, juggled. And
in the end, the winner might as well be
selected at random. That can certainly
be fun. But it turns the game into a
toy, a shared experience without a clear
competitive goal. And I wasn't a fan of
that, either. So, the happy medium had
to be found. Now, did you know that the
average Magic player has an attention
span of 4.7 seconds? So, while I still
have yours, I want to talk about my
sponsor, Card Kingdom Power TCG. They
make excellent boxes, sleeves, dice, all
of that. And I approached them for this
sponsorship cuz I was just a huge fan of
their aesthetics. So, yeah, take a look
at their site. And if you like the
stuff, use my code levels, all caps, for
a discount. So, where was I? Happy
medium. Yes, because we still wanted to
win, but I've come to believe that what
truly matters is how we win. This is a
useful metric because it applies just as
well when we lose. How did we lose?
Commander, to me, is a lot like a
single-player video game. Beating the
game on the easiest difficulty is
simple. But if you stay there, just
crushing your opponents over and over
and over, you never grow. The real
challenge, the real satisfaction, comes
from getting better. And in this case,
achieving the same goal, but adding
difficulties and restrictions.
And as I mentioned, I got bored of Simic
pretty quickly, but the small being
mentality stuck around for much longer.
I laid low and played into politics like
everyone else until I tried aggro.
Which, for the longest time, I didn't
think was an option in EDH. I remember
opening an Aurelia, the War Leader, in
the Gatecrash pre-release, and it
changed everything. She gave aggro decks
the ability to finish games. Pop down
threats, see the fear in my opponent's
eyes, set up for Aurelia, and watch my
board get wiped.
Yeah, that deck didn't win a lot of
games, but I noticed it was an enjoyable
experience almost every game. Win or
lose, at least I did something, and I
always posed a threat. And that wasn't
always the case with a lot of my other
decks. So, that flicked a switch. No
more small bean. We walk into the room,
slam dick onto the table, and force
everyone to deal with us. When we win is
against all odds, and when we lose,
it'll feel like a boss fight for our
opponents. Now, of course, to get to
this point, it took a fair bit of trial
and error. Even just achieving the
average 25% win rate is quite an
accomplishment with how we're choosing
to play. And today, we'll be going over
how to get there. Let's start with the
traditional aggro decks. Now, this is by
no means a comprehensive guide to
playing aggressive, but the core
philosophy is fairly simple. We start
off guns blazing, not that we're able to
win or even kill anyone from that, but
the goal is to chip out opponents' life
totals enough to force them into playing
the game a little bit differently. Maybe
chump blocking with an utility creature
or thinking twice before drawing an
extra card with Underworld Connections,
but we fall off pretty quickly after
this initial surge, and what happens
after requires some careful engineering.
Specifically, we want to catch our
opponents with surprises. It can come in
many different forms, the most direct
being these doubling and tripling spells
that turn a manageable board into
lethal, or a protection spell in
response to a board wipe that our
opponents are banking on, or the late
game combo of Flash and Haste. Nearly
every opponent in every deck will have a
shields down moment, and exploiting that
moment usually means securing a kill and
possibly the game. And if there happens
to be another aggro or beatdown deck,
make sure to threat assess properly.
Most of the time, they aren't your enemy
yet. The turtling combo decks are.
Voltron is similar in that at first, you
probably don't want to take out one
player too quickly, even if you can, for
the sake of play experience. So, I
generally try to keep each opponent at
just above one. Say our commander is a
6/6, we won't be setting our opponents
to above 12 commander damage. Try to
keep them from feeling the immediate
threat and kill with surprises when the
need arises.
It's definitely tricky to navigate,
though.
For a slightly easier time, we can take
advantage of some of these ridiculous
legends that hit like a truck, but also
refund you some value. With commanders
like Bruna, Cloud, and Jin-Gitaxias,
you'll never worry about over-committing
because you recoup your cards and more.
And speaking of recouping your cards,
well, it turns out Civic also happens to
be one of the best beatdown colors for
its ability to keep the gas flowing
through board wipe after board wipe
after board wipe. One of my favorite
decks of all time is Prime Speaker
Zegana playing the double homesteaders
and using Arc Mage to recoup all that
lost card advantage. All while firing
off big ramp spells in between to set up
for mid to late game. And once we're
set, your opponents are not keeping your
board empty. Farewell in response
tapping those for 10 mana and Genesis
Wave for eight at the end of turn with
the help of Alchemist's Refuge. If
you've ever played against the horde
magic decks, this feels a lot like that.
Just waves and waves of relentless
beats. Colors and commanders that can
provide this constant stream of
resources is rare. An alternative is
decks that can scale with the format.
Enable for fast enough kills even with
three opponents and thus able to justify
going all or nothing. The prime example
of this is token decks going wide plus
mass pump is basically the textbook
definition of scaling to the format. But
there's also commanders that provide
this kind of reach. Arabella is a
personal favorite, effectively tripling
the damage you can do with one power
weenies. Mishra does something similar.
Also look for commanders that can double
and double again, whether it's going
tall or wide. And last but not least, we
have the group slug strategies. Decks
like Sofium, Croxa, and Mogis. At first,
your opponents may be alerted, but
different decks want the table to be at
different life totals, and it isn't
always 40. So you may eventually be able
to find like-minded individuals or even
temporary allies. This also applies to
the play style as a whole. As a play
group matures, it will learn to fairly
assess and even appreciate proactive
decks. Because we are the ones who toss
out questions and demand answers,
keeping the dirty decks in check and
setting a limit on how far they can go
with their greed. This is by no means a
comprehensive guide but hopefully will
set you on the right path to being the
big bad in your group. This is Jin with
next level commander. Thank you for
watching.
If you like this kind of content like
and subscribe. I usually do tech talks
but sometimes I talk about the format
and also check out my sponsor Kakapopo
use my code levels all caps and I'll see
you in my next video.